[Music]
hello and welcome to another
night of chess on psychology i am dorsa
directiony
uh surprisingly at the club instead of
being home hanging out with gmpg
um i hope you guys are having a great
week i can't believe it's
almost almost february i know it's not
but
i've been ordering my books for the
beginning of semester which starts
um next week thursday so it's been a
little
um a little messy just running around
but i still can't believe it my winter
break is almost over
but besides my winter break uh the other
fun thing that's been going on
is the uh tata still tournament well
sorry wickenzie tournament which is the
83rd
tata steel masters i'm quite
glad that this is actually happening
live and
um in person instead of most of the
tournaments that we've been having and
they've been
online um i i i still
i've played online tournaments but i
still prefer
in like in person i actually want to sit
down i want to squeeze my head i want to
be able to
stare into my opponent's eyes i like
that i like that environment i want to
be able to
kind of read your mind i want to be able
to
see and like do the little mind tricks i
prefer that way more than
just uh playing from behind a computer
but
well uh until there is actual vaccine
that everybody has taken and this
we've defeated this disease it's um
online chess for me well uh besides that
so
um there was few games and tata still or
awakened z that
have been pretty amazing and um
so one of them that i've heard so much
about and i've looked into
for a while and i really did enjoy was
the game that magnus played with firo's
job
um well with that alireza and
it's very interesting especially because
first of all i played in vacancy not in
this tournament not in the super
tournament goddamn
and i did play and um there was like a
close tournament event that i played in
2015 i absolutely loved it i believe it
was called the cultural village
i've shown few of my games from there i
intend to show a little bit more of them
too
and um i really uh it was such a great
tournament because if i remember
correctly if you won the tournament
you would be invited to play in the b
tournament this is the masters the other
one would be the b
tournament which is still super strong
and i did not win that tournament but i
had a lot of great experiences and a lot
of great games
and anyways so let's go ahead and get
started with the
game that carlson and fearusdra played
um it's also a little funny because
last week when i was showing the uh i
was teaching this class
i talked about how um baby magnus was
playing in this tournament
like 2008 and i was kind of comparing
him with elira's a little so
seeing them actually clash and how it
went down was extremely interesting too
for me
so just a second let me close this part
oh nope i don't want to close the wi-fi
i want to close the sound there we go
um so it was a very interesting game
um well to be honest i play
bishop b4s here or b6 mainly
um so it was very great
to actually get the chance to
i used to play d5 but for some reason i
i remember i had a few horrible losses
in d5 and
i kind of switched my openings and
yes i am also reading the chat so that's
why there will be a lot of head shifting
because i have
my chat right here uh yeah
all right thank you thank you i see a
lot of positive notes a lot of great
questions thank you
um so there's a question about if i was
analyzing calcium games in 2008 yes
um not just in 2008 but in this specific
tournament in 2008
so feel free to go and check that
lecture out it was last week
citizen psychology um so but for this
week let's just try
and i have two games that i really do
want to get through so
i might go a little faster on the
opening
but i do enjoy this it was such a great
game
all right so this is not somewhat of a
normal
uh queen's gambit and there are some
ideas with bishop e7
there are some ideas with b6 ideally
sometime
later there could be either a c6 or
something with like b65 it's so many so
many so many different possibilities
but one thing that's certain is bishop
has to come out to e7 so for those of
you who
are not as comfortable um playing
in this opening because you don't play
this well i don't play this as black
but i do know the general ideas i gotta
have
my bishop out on e7
for example i gotta be able to um
get this bishop out i know i want to do
short castle so do the things that you
know you want to do now
my first question for the audience take
what do you think we should do should we
take it back with pawn or knight and i
know this might sound like a
weird question to those of you who know
these
but if you don't know this opening this
answer might be a little challenging to
you
so wow somebody watching from tehran
awesome
oh if i was analyzing games 13 years ago
i
i don't know where i would be today but
no 13 years ago i was a
10 year old oh my god i'm almost 23
years old just hit me
years are flying by
yeah we should start with pawn you guys
are correct uh however
in this game i really decided to take
with knight the problem the thing is you
could take it to the pawn but this
this kind of gets into a weird call
split pawn structure because
now later on you're gonna do the c6 and
you have to do this bishop f5
but the problem is that your knight is a
little bit on the way
but at the same time you could do like
this knight f8 ideas there's a lot of
different ways to achieve this
um but there are a lot of the times in
this uh crossword pawn structure and
crossbow pawn structure is these two
pawns against these two
pawns this diagonal matters so
so so much so it's really important to
try to
take advantage of that so black will
want to do this white will want to do
this
and a lot of the times this knight on d7
is not the best choice sometimes it's
good to have it on a6 i remember that
one of the first games that i saw that
was
around this idea was with knight a6 the
palmers on c6 and the knight started
jumping around
and i really did enjoy that if i'm not
mistaken that was a kasparov game but
this is like 10 years ago that i
saw this um so my memory might be a
little
um not as reliable
but generally this is a good idea this
is one of the common ideas to try to get
out the knight to a6 um
so what does get yeah that is true um so
however in the game ali rizzo decided to
take with knights nothing
wrong with that take take e4 let's take
over here
now this is the different type of pawn
structure there is no more
that called splat pawn structures the
center is somewhat mobile
mobile and your bishop is probably going
to come out from one of these two
squares right
so that's another thing to keep in mind
um so in the game black just castle
logical bishop d3 now another question
for you the audience what do you think
black should do we already discussed the
possibility of getting this bishop out
so you have
one choice that you could go for but at
the same time peace activity
center space make sure you consider all
of those fun
ideas before you
before you actually suggest
a move
and i am monitoring the chat closely
all right um
i like the idea yeah i like the idea of
c5 so yeah exactly this is
like a graph field but without my bishop
on g7
yeah c5 seems to be the most desirable
one
so let's say you play your c5 and now
the thing is if you
well white's never going to take that
because now the
all these pawn structures are so um
problematic for white as well as now
this light is super active no you should
never take that uh-uh
uh white rightfully castled black
continued with take
take and now finally our b6
so there is a small pawn majority over
here
that could be beneficial for black in
the long run
in the ntn especially when we're
thinking about pass bonds
but right now we're not there so we
shouldn't start jumping
ahead and thinking about end game but as
we said
there is this pawn majority that black
could try to use
so white to move what do you think we
should do as white
there are still few pieces that you
should develop
um to be honest i like where your bishop
is placed don't don't touch that bishop
but there are other things that could be
improved rookie one possible
but not necessarily that needed at the
moment
all right um queen e2 possible again
but i see a lot of different ideas like
rookie one queen a4 trying to pin the
queen
um trying to go queen e2 ah
great a4 finally somebody a4
is great because it's kind of fun to
follow up with a move such as a5
or even if you don't want to do a5 you
are at least putting
some strain on sorry
a6 b5s oops
i apologize so um
that's another idea that at least it's
kind of putting
white but white's putting a little bit
of strain on black's
pawn movements and i do like that idea
so
after a4 normal development now quick
question
should we play a5 or should we just let
it be
should we just play some normal moves
like just develop
queen e2 rookie one keep in mind if you
play a5 on its exchange you have a clear
target to go after
but at the same time then you also give
your opponent a passed pawn
so kind of your choice which one do you
think will benefit you
more
all right i see some ideas going
potentially e5
um all right so far i don't see anybody
rooting for a5 interesting
oh i apologize which kind of jumps
my bad my bad um
okay whoops i guess i can't be in two
leeches that counts
two positions at once oops okay
yes um i do see some ideas that
do support a5 and i like that i think we
should do this a5
um a5 is great your whole idea with a4
was to play a5 so do it
um after you do this a5 um i see some
ideas with queen b1
that could be interesting but not not
just yet
and the issue is that if you played this
queen b1
um i feel it's too early
and you also might allow your opponent
to play a5
or simply maybe just knight f6 now if
you play a5 now i don't really have to
keep my rook here i can just activate my
rook
um queen b1 could be interesting but you
still have to follow it up with a5
so let's just do a5 and then we can
decide where to place the queen
take take now do you want queen b1
or do you want rook e1 to defend this
pawn
i think um to be honest queen d1 does
not really flow as well with me
just because there might be some rook
v8s
there's rook b5 so i'm not that worried
about it
but at the same time i would prefer it
not to be there
so
yeah i feel like rookie one might be the
safer choice because then i want to do
queen to a1 and i wanna
battery my rook with my queen
so in the game uh there's a play direct
d8
now let's do the queen swing and
in the game i was a little um just a
little bit
um uncertain about this move but it
makes sense
but magnus played h3 it kind of makes
sense because you don't want to deal
with background checkmates you don't
want to deal with knight g4s
so it's such a great prophylaxi move but
at the same time um
i was just thinking if should should you
try and maybe still move the queen a
little
try to bring the rook um there's still i
feel like there's so many ideas here
um but they're all connected on the
queen side so it's a good idea to
open a little something for your king in
the king side
and there was never a free pawn to eat i
wish
uh if you played rook a7 if you're
referring to that the problem
is that's now requosed to a8 and even
you have to do queen c5 and even after
the queen exchange
this is not this is not a free pawn just
king can go to f8
york c1 then he can eat over here
and no this is not a free pawn if you
don't play rook c1 let's say what like
maybe king goes over here
rook goes to see it you are going to
have to drop one of these two so it's
not
a um it's not a free pawn
um there's some confusion about the
control of open c
file um it is true there is a small
battle on the control of c
file but the main point is this guy
we want to be able to eat the free pawn
but we can't do that just yet we have to
prepare for it so we play this h3
as a prophylaxis move and then
now we can try to go back to our focus
of the c file
now uh this move also was
a little interesting for me what do you
think
uh here white should do black just made
this
interesting move to jump into the
king side uh putting more forces on my
pawn
what do you think we should do
i don't know if any of you guys is like
me
but i started carrying around my own tea
because i i like specific set of teas so
it's a little weird when i go
somewhere and they don't have it so
um yes in us they're so much
bigger on green tea and fruity tea i
want my tea black i want it
a little flavor so like earl grey or
english breakfast but
they usually don't have those so weird
anyways um i like i kind of like the
idea with queen c1
but i don't think this end game is that
beneficial for
us uh we should only go to the end game
when we're completely sure that we're
doing great
for example if we could take with this
rook and my pawn was not going to be e10
that's
i could consider that but keep in mind
when we go to the end game
the past pawn it rook behind it
not maybe i don't really wanna if this
pawn didn't exist yeah we could go to
the end game
but also a little hint this is a one
i don't know if you guys have heard
about this but that's the famous game
that
uh magnus kind of um
uh gabe alire is a cute lesson
in the middle game so we don't really
want to exchange the queens just giving
you a little hint
all right so uh rookie five is the move
um we don't want to play this e5 either
careful we don't wanna
allow some activity for our opponents or
key five we don't wanna lose this pawn
we wanna try and potentially
uh say hi to your queen potentially
so uh in the game knight one to d7 k5
knight f6 now you're faced with a
question
should i repeat should you repeat you
you know that's in the game uh carson
didn't repeat
but that doesn't stop you from sharing
your opinion
on if you should repeat or not so do you
think you should repeat
i always repeat i wish that would make
chess so much easier
you would just go in repeat three moves
nobody would ever win
wow
would i say this bishop is more powerful
than this bishop
no because my bishop is also attacking
your pawn
uh under right circumstances maybe but
at the moment no these bishops i
don't find one more one stronger because
they're both
um defenseless they're both attacking a
set of pawn
um so yes oh interesting
nice d5 good job you guys
um it's like kind of like
now or never type of deal because if you
play a joke e5 then you would just have
two loops
then you would just have to keep
repeating and you don't want to repeat
so d5 take now e5
knight goes to e4 now question
how should we deal with this knight one
thing is for sure we should not take it
because i like my bishop your knight is
good but it's not that good
also if you take it then you're
attacking line knights your pawn becomes
stronger you have e3 your rook opens so
i should not take it so now that we know
we don't want to take it
how else this is a funny thing that i
said as a joke
a lot a few months ago and somehow the
more
uh games i see the more i feel like wow
well is that
something like rule that nobody ever
told me but
as a joke a few months ago i said
you should always if you don't know what
to do and if your position allows you
you should always centralize your queen
when i said it i was joking i admit that
but seriously the more games i see the
more i find the situations that i can
actually
do this cool queen d4 stuff so let's do
it
um group goes to c8 also i assume
to be honest again in this position
and this is good position for white
not because we haven't we have advantage
but because
when we gave up a pawn we still have a
compensation
so if you give up a pawn and your
position still
shows uh complicated or zero zero point
zero zero blah blah
if it's if it's if it doesn't give your
opponent advantage when you sacrifice
upon it that's a good position you want
that position it means you have good
compensation
so um rook c8
and in this game we uh
sorry magnus played rook a1
this was also a little cool slash
surprising to me
because this move allows for a5 which
eliriza did and now rook goes to b1
so this was such an interesting rook
maneuver
because now when you move your bishop to
c6
you are kind of blocking your rook but
bishop a6 is supposedly the better idea
to try and get into this position
however even with that uh that tablet
also sorry
i didn't finish my thought process uh
with this
again there is a lot of different ways
for
black to fight so it's not such a cut
and dry position but it
white has higher piece activity better
chances for seventh rank
some ideas with the pawn maybe so it's
still a huge fight
but my point being that bishop a6 would
be a better choice for black
now with bishop c6 what do you think we
should do so
white to move how can we try to make
this game even more interesting
um so manish we play this queen d4 for
both
reasons we like queen d4 because we
we like it because it's multifunctional
it also centralizes
also pins also gives also stops this so
blockades
and that's one of the beauties with
having a centralized queen it has so
many different things
i see our idea with e6 why do you guys
think e6 is a good idea you would just
give up a second pawn
whoops i do like this idea
but
all right i'm still seeing some
suggestions
on maybe rook
moving to b6 stroke moving to c1
they're all possible but um
it's still not that that great idea that
you want to have
so tell me why not e6
why what don't we like about e6
all right um we don't want to trade
these bishops my opponent wants to trace
these bishops
so let's take a look for e6 e6 he kind
of got to take it right because if you
don't take it now
i might take it or might play e7 you
should take it
now what does this e6 give us
all right
square for tonight there we go you guys
got it yeah let's go
you got a square for tonight that was
the goal now
uh let's say you do the square for the
night and you might
want to do some cool f6 ideas maybe to
try and win this night
let's say the queen moves now what do
you still do this f3
this is kind of funny so um in the
i think it was at this point that um
the official commenter i think it was
like peter lico
said that if white wasn't two pawns down
i would say he's completely winning
but the fun thing is that it's still
fine white's still doing great with
being two pawns down
so what do you think we should do
all right um i see the idea with if you
play f3 there's knight g3
but that's not that doesn't really um
not done g3 isn't really doing much
because well you could do this
attack the queen and when the queen
moves this pawn is falling
so it doesn't really do much for why a
black's position
if rpi there's this cool bishop g6 idea
too
so what do we think is f3 still useful
exquisite that's quite interesting i
know chess packs are
useful but it depends what type of test
books you read
i never really liked doing tactics from
chess books
i liked doing actual readings like
strategy or dynamic chess from chess
books
okay so i see that you guys are warming
up to this
idea with um
with f3 all right let's go for f3
to be fair taking over here is perfectly
doable
this is again perfectly doable but the
problem is that when you actually
exchange all of these material
now as white you're just hoping for a
draw
it's funny um one of our viewers does
really does not like f3 because it wicks
the squares
i kind of agree with that not exactly my
first pick either or my first thoughts
but
f3 is awesome because when he moved the
knight
now uh this knight was active i kicked
it away
now i keep activating my own pieces this
is something that i've been talking
about a lot in our um digital classrooms
with just attack attack attack peace
activity peace activity
so peace activity that bob
uh the the the idea of you're at least
getting one pawn back after roof b6
that's kind of a good idea yeah but in
when you sacrifice
these two pawns as a sack or as a
strategical sacrifice you shouldn't want
to actively try to get them back
that's kind of the the little trade-off
you give them up you don't know if
you're ever going to get them back
but you get peace activity so after rook
p6 bishop goes away queen e3
i am still reorganizing my pieces
so i have some ideas for your e6 all
right
i'm poking your e6 and now should i take
over here
keep in mind the knight is still here so
maybe i could play like an h4 reverse
or should i take it right away
yep so let's take it take we take it
uh this position just looks scary um
so if black survives black has extra
material right
but it's so super dangerous so let's say
after bishop f7
what do you think we should do as white
if i came all the way here to just play
like a normal move such as queen of five
then i probably am doing something wrong
to be fair bishop of seven was a blunder
the best move
was king sh8 queen comes now give a
check
and then bishop g6 and then you would uh
go in this game and
this pawn is a mini monster
um but it's okay we can we still white
is not lost there's
still a perfect fight going on but my
point being
that this would have given black the
best chance
uh but black did not do this he simply
played bishop f7
and yeah night sack there we go take
take take
i want to give you simple checkmates um
white black just played queen c7 but
that just doesn't really make sense
either
we black is a little busted check
check check and finishing
oh well here actually here's your resign
but i just want to finish it off
it feels too cute can i just go anywhere
let's just go over here
feels cuter because i get to meet you
with the pawn yay
yeah this was a perfect game uh from
magnus
he sacrificed these two pawns and then
he
sacrificed the rook and then a knight
what else could you sacrifice uh it was
a great game
i really enjoyed it so i hope you did
too
if you have any questions from this game
let me know if not i'm gonna jump ahead
to the next one um
yeah just i'm gonna give the viewers
maybe uh
20 30 seconds for
questions if not
let's go
okay
all right any questions let's go uh
no i wish there was an opportunity for
black to sacrifice too
okay so this is a game between duda
and uh grendelius niels
if i'm not mistaken i might be
gratefully mistaken
but i know i mistake it i was thinking
nils
came to iran once to play in the
tournaments but i keep
i think i'm mistaken if anybody want to
do a quick fact check feel free to do
that and let me know
i'm pretty sure i'm wrong but
um i don't do that never came to run for
tournament that much i know
um anyways um
okay so i see still no questions yay
great let's go it's still from the same
tournament i think this is just the
second round of the event
so c4 i don't play
i play e5 myself but c5 is another
i mean it's a perfect opening nothing
wrong with it you play c5 you go
uh yeah yes i agree dudes game should
come with a warning label i
agree that's actually a very interesting
way to put it
so knight f3 and i see six
and uh we are as black just trying to
get some of the
center get some of our pieces out
this uh i like playing this ideas with
fiona kettle but
my problem is it always scares me when
there is a knight d5
if i don't really want to give up that
outpost
however black knows what he is doing
no need to worry um now i have just
i want to take a tiny pause and ask
a little bit of questions from the
audience so just
general ideas what do you think is
black's
ideas so where do you think black wants
to play
most likely there will be a f5 at some
point
probably not just yet there should be
something in the queen side
not entirely sure what just yet
um i don't think center is going to do
much because if you're going to have
king side attack we want the center to
be stable
i agree he probably does want something
with f5 and b5s
what else now what do you think white
wants
ah rahul that's so sweet of you i hope
you enjoy the chess
all right so i i see that you guys are
all pretty much agreeing on these ideas
all right wyatt probably wants to move
this knight to activate this monstrous
bishop i
like that probably there will be a
knight d5 sooner or later
i agree with that too what else
i think that's the kind of the main idea
so let's go for it
well black played rook b8 you guys are
correct
we want to um just try and push
right all right so 91
and not exactly the knight d2 you
expected but
the idea is kind of similar white wants
to try and potentially get this knight
to e3
so we can start having a fun
time on d5 so now white
plays white has this idea so black
logically plays bishop to e6
stopping some knight d5s and not really
stopping but at least bringing more
material to face it queen d7
knight c2 trying to go to e3 and
now black to move what do you think
black should do
i agree we should probably be able to
kick this knight on d5
but the problem is the it doesn't really
work
that well just yet
oh king of shades for f5 maybe
but
what is my queen doing here
could this queen potentially be looking
a little towards the queen side too
sorry king slides too
yeah bishop h3 there we go the ideas
with b5 are
all valid but not just yet let's get
rid of this bishop first if i have to
open up this side i don't wanna
i don't want you to have that ginormous
bishop staring at my
queen side queen d2 bam boom
now f5 f4 probably coming on e4 probably
coming on a bunch of different ideas
so uh in the game white duda
played b4 uh this was kind of an
interesting
opening because uh b4 is not
exactly that desired for white to play
because apparently this move f4 but this
is a novelty nobody has played this
before
again to be completely clear b4 is not
such a
hot move it's not like everybody plays
it's not like berlin
so it's perfectly fine to play b4 and do
a novelty
against it so this f4 okay
so now um i like this f4 for different
reasons
because well first of all if you take
take
that kind of helps my pawn structure
just a little bit
second of all no more knight d3s for you
and
third of all if i took it you could take
back
and you could take over here and
everything would start to just get
exchanged and i don't want to exchange
that much
and if if you keep exchanging pieces
you lose all the chances not sorry
not all you lose a lot of the chances
that
um could help you improv activate your
pieces
go kind of poke your opponent's king
torture him a little by
pushing your pawns and using your
activated pieces
so you don't want to lose all of your
toys and tools and pieces so
let's not do that so
f4 now yeah this is so
far in the theory there are there's some
of the lines that a lot of
not every line not every opening that i
play but a lot of the openings that i
play frequently
um especially in sicilian there are
theory up until move like
20 25 that you have to know um
but there are also a lot of the openings
that i play and i
don't know the opening up that deep i
know probably about
15 moves in and those are usually the
openings that are so
rarely being played with me i don't get
the chance to review them as often
over the board and i don't get to
prepare against the opponents
but anyways
that's why i like 962. yeah chess 960
does kind of take that element away but
i am very good at preparing it as my
opponent so i like that
i want to know who i play i want to have
time to prepare all right
take take um
yeah exquisite that is true the more you
get to play with people the more
lines there are for you to analyze after
that's great
all right so quick question my opponent
just played e4
now i have three things to do with this
pawn take
push or take does anybody want to do any
of them
okay i see a lot of push and some don't
push
okay i see some people are coming up on
board with pushing i like it let's push
if you could do like this little
checkmates why not it kind of gives you
that uh combination
squares so king h1
um white plays knight
sorry kingish one white did that white
might have some ideas to want to defend
this
square with knights right so maybe we
can try and
get rid of this knight how boom knight
d4
if you take it perfect now no more nice
to cover up your king if you don't take
it
as uh duda didn't uh did it just took on
e7
which makes perfect sense because if you
don't take it i will take it
if you play it something like knight to
e3 the other problem is now i can just
play bishop to h6 that doesn't help you
either
so take take at least it misplaced the
queen a little bit
now this makes me think maybe i could
simply take this first
and then do knight d4 but then again you
could do
bishop d4 or it's not as strong
i would assume but again this is
perfectly doable too i think this would
also be a
tiny improvement on knight d4 first
because i just don't
like my queen getting misplaced all
right
yeah we can do a rook lift too i like
that idea so white played knight e3
two options we have this idea with
bishop h6 which i think is too early
we have the other option of just go back
and you wanna still keep up with the
same idea
which one do you think we should do
i agree let's be both be annoying let's
play queen d7
very well put jaroslav let's go
um in the game dude that took i take
attacking your knight
you move this poor guy and this move was
a little funny for me
not laughing funny just like how did i
not think about it funny
i'll give you guys maybe about 30
seconds this is not like
it's not like you have making two or
three don't don't
don't think like that it was just a
funny idea that i didn't think about
so what do you guys think
all right so um to be honest
it's funny it's just so funny rook e8 uh
the idea of
rook lift was mentioned before and then
i remember i was thinking maybe g5
at some point try to push that but this
can't come up and then i was struggling
to use this rook to actually get it to
h5 and then i was like why didn't i
think about the other rook
so let's just bring the other rook um
white plays rook g1 not queen g4
no cute g4s for you today my friend
um but the problem with queen g4
is actually this is also kind of funny
the problem is
queen a5 because now you're kind of
going
and starting to eat my pawns and if i
play rook e5
knight goes to f4 bishop h6 there's not
much for whites to worry about
even if all these happens still i can
just play like a rook g3
white is completely defending and this
actually reminds me of a game that i
showed a few weeks ago when i played um
ruth padmini that game was i was also
attacking
but my opponents she took my attack way
too seriously and she blundered and
i just won super easily this is somewhat
like that because
if your opponent just didn't
if your opponent just didn't take this
attack so seriously so if for black
if white was just like yeah i trust my
defense with the rook
i'm fine i'm going to go eat your pawns
this would have been somewhat equal
still black has a certain attack but
the problem is queen g4 wasn't as
accurate
rook e5 just made more sense or
or b6 first no more queen a5s if you
play g4
i'll just go over here i will go to the
other side
anyways i can understand why queen g4 is
so tempting don't know geforce 3u
white fell into trap queen d1 and now
black just has an easy game
uh knight f4 and white uh
this is the last kind of like last stand
for white what do you think black should
do
yeah queen a5 is quite amazing and it's
quite beautiful and it's so
weird
yeah let's go g5
now white play this h3 i move by queen
uh again if you move your knight i'll
just give you checkmate so
white just took over here and we could
take it but the problem is after take
um white gets a little certain set of
activity that we don't want to give him
so nobody's rushing me let's just move
my rook back first
now you move her up nobody's rushing me
to eat this i'll just keep on staring at
it
now now that when you move the night
when you move the queen away the knight
is not pinned anymore boom boom
i'll eat your pawn this was the easiest
way so don't
rush it just because there's free
material doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to take it right away
okay so take take
take over here and this bishop is going
to be pretty monstrous
so hopefully at some point all right
let's save my king away
because i'll poke your queen a little
bit and
again queen f4 i just want to go eat
some pawns man
um so now quick question why do
white play the c5 what do you think we
should do
should we take it over here should we
take it over there
there are different ways but
hi manny what's up
to be honest i think both of them win
there's so there's so few moves that
don't win as long as you're not
giving free stuff to your opponent
taking is great
and then i can just play queen e5 and
that's actually what happened in the
game too to be honest uh queen f2 is
another
quite interesting line and then you
could take over here
it'll take that back and um
then i can just try to maybe come back
with the queen it's
doable nothing wrong with it the thing
is we have one more bishop so
that makes my life so much easier
and this makes perfect sense you are
just attacking you're just
uh going after eating more pawns you're
still keeping your pieces all activated
and all defended
by each other and whoa whoa whoa no no
where did my board go sorry
now black to move what do you think is
the last blow
yeah sorry guys no gm pushy for you
today he will join us tomorrow
i think queen f3 is doable there's so
many things that are doable
but the problem with queen f3 is i don't
want to give you my
this rook by this um precious
g7 so in order to do this queen f3 in
order to make it doable
we do a rookie 7. now i want to play
queen f3 in exchange
while my rook is defending it yeah
i really did enjoy this game it was the
the first game the magnus versus
it was just so just boom boom boom boom
sacrifices punch that over there and
then this one do the
and the nails it was so um chill
like it was so logical and and
like duda only made few few mistakes
that he
that wouldn't really look that bad um
but he still didn't really manage to
save the game even though there were few
uh options the opening kind of got to
him in that from the middle game from
somewhere around
i want to say when he's like when he
played this b4
he didn't really stood that much of a
chance
so it was a little rough um
opening slash middle game for him but
yeah
unfortunately so i hope that they will
all have a perfect tournament going on
we can only have one winner but i hope
everybody enjoyed their time in
wickenzie i did enjoy my time there
and um hopefully we will
continue to see some awesome chess
um we are gonna go take a quick five
minute break
and we will be back for our insane
or intense all of those in india it's
gonna be intense and insane
so don't go anywhere be go grab a coffee
or something
be back in about five minutes and
um yeah i hope to see you soon
[Music]
you